[Music]
anyone here see the supermoon this past
Saturday night did you see this
the moon was closer than usual to the
earth so it looked much bigger than
normal it looked massive and this got me
a little annoyed a fret they don't know
what the big deal is we've had a super
moon here on our show since day one and
yeah and and our key grip Terry can tell
you all about it Terry well that's right
Conan it's really big and it's right
there right by behind you over there
thanks Terry all right just leave the
quarter there Terry ladies and gentlemen
I wanted to know don't put it back get
out Terry ladies and gentlemen I'd like
to take a second and apologize for how
stupid that bit was it was unforgivably
lame and I beg to differ Conan I
represent the goddard space scholarship
Institute and these silly comedy
sketches can actually inspire young
minds to take an interest in astronomy
that's I'm glad you approve thank you
very much doctor appreciate it whoa a
quarter
you